q flow pipelines are made up of a series
of components that give you an ml work
flow naturally you'll want to improve
those workflows over time like their
performance efficiency and accuracy q
flow metadata is a central thing to help
you do just that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you want to check out the
documentation directly check out the
link below to read more about metadata
on cue flow the goal of the metadata
project is to help cue flow users
understand and manage their machine
learning workflows by tracking and
managing the metadata that the workflows
produce not only is it useful to improve
your results but it's important for
audit and compliance reasons so you can
know which models are in production and
what their characteristics are here
metadata means information about
executions or runs models datasets and
other artifacts artifacts are the files
and objects that form the inputs and
outputs of the components in your ml
workflow cube flow comes with a metadata
component installed by default which is
used for storing and serving metadata
you can write to the metadata server
from your own code and in addition some
cute flow components log metadata about
their activities automatically then the
cue flow UI lets you view the logged
metadata in particular cue flow
pipelines automatically logs information
about a run including workflow artifacts
executions and lineage you can see this
pipelines feature in action with the
cloud AI platforms pipelines
installation models and datasets can
then be visualized in the metadata web
UI so that you can start tracking them
out of the box with no extra work
required you just need to head to the
artifact store in the left-hand panel
behind the scenes queue Flo is handling
the metadata through ml MD a library for
recording and retrieving metadata ml MD
is an integral part of tensorflow
extended but it's designed to be used
independently cube flow helps you use
metadata for all components of your ml
workflow it comes with a metadata API
and corresponding clients and you can
install the metadata SDK a Python
library that makes it easy to write to
the metadata server cube flow pipelines
automatically logs metadata during a
pipeline run this lets you track the
definition of artifacts for things like
pipeline versions and when they were
last updated the metadata to evaluate an
execution of your pipeline like the run
ID inputs and outputs and the metadata
about the pipeline and associated
lineage information so you can clearly
see how artifacts and their associated
metadata relate to one another in
addition to queue flow pipelines
automatic tracking you can manually
write to the metadata server to collect
additional metadata like the metadata
for a data set that forms inputs and
outputs like a description path
and query metrics used to evaluate an ml
model like the accuracy and learning
rate and the metadata for an ml model
that your workflow produces like the
model type hyper parameters and labels
let's walk through an example of writing
to the metadata server I'm running a
sample m-miss classifier model in my
jupiter notebook server after i execute
a run i can log a dataset model
evaluation of the model and metadata for
serving the model once I'm in the
artifact store I can see a list of items
for all the metadata events that my
workflows have logged I can see an
example of the model metrics and dataset
metadata with a name my table dump
besides using the SDK to log metadata
directly you can also add your own
metadata watcher to watch kubernetes
resource changes it extracts metadata
from some kubernetes api objects and
logs them to the queue flow metadata
service to learn more and try out this
notebook and explore its metadata check
out the links below and stay tuned to
learn more
[Music]
[Applause]